John lleva una pistola desde principios
de los años 60
es una de las 76.200 personas con
licencia en el estado de Nueva York para
aportarla la demanda de armas se ha
disparado en el último mes a pesar de
que no es fácil caminar por la ciudad
armado
sí tengo que ir a la corte a recoger un
arma tengo que pensar por dónde voy si
voy a pasar por algún colegio o algún
mercado de calle tengo que planear mi
ruta para así no violar las
restricciones en esas áreas
este es uno de los pocos lugares donde
puede moverse libremente con su arma
asegura que la nueva ley donde se
prohíbe el porte de armas en algunas
zonas públicas es una venganza de la
gobernadora de Nueva York a la decisión
de la Corte Suprema
has escuchado la expresión diente por
diente tú haces algo yo voy a hacer algo
así que cuando la Corte Suprema salió
con esa Norma el gobernador salió con
algo que oponía esa Norma
Pero hay excepciones y Johnny es una de
ellas un policía retirado que puede
llevar su pistola encima Incluso en el
famoso kilómetro cero de la gran manzana
el policía que esté activo o fuera de
servicio o un policía retirado como soy
yo que me acabo de retirar carteles como
este marcan la zona libre de armas pero
son casi imperceptibles
el criminal no va a obedecer a esa
señalización según Johnny con esta nueva
Norma que incluye 13 cuadras solo se
castiga a quienes tienen una licencia de
armas un juez bloqueó partes de esta
nueva ley y ahora la fiscal general de
Nueva York ha pelado el fallo las
autoridades defienden el equilibrio que
es asegurarse que la gente propietario
responsable de armas puedan ejecutar sus
derechos constitucionales pero al mismo
tiempo asegurarnos de que todo el mundo
es consciente de cuáles son las reglas y
también se sientan seguros la batalla
legal ha comenzado y en medio están
ellos propietarios de licencias que solo
les queda seguir muy de cerca las nuevas
normas